okay welcome to the the second session
of the day so you heard this morning
about about classical algorithms and
today we're gonna fight back this
session we'll fight back with with
quantum algorithms and our first speaker
is Fernando Grandal who tell us about
quantum algorithms for semi-definite
programs Thank You Aaron hi everyone so
this is joint work with with Chris this
war also known as chair of crappy 2017
so it's so okay we we have a common goal
here all of us we follow experimental
friends we want to one day build a
quantum computer right so and we have as
theories we would like to understand
what we will use the quantum computer
once we have one and we learn a lot
about that in the past 20 years
we know sometimes you can have
explanation speed ups that many great
applications like simulate quantum
physics or just factor really big
numbers there's sometimes for other
problems we have more modest speed ups
with su interesting for example
searching Robins away from now we have a
bunch of other examples and there's also
feasible understand less that they might
become relevant applications of a
quantum computer but maybe you have to
wait and should we have one to figure it
out and that's like many heuristics that
we know for example quantum annealing or
adiabatic utilization and so on which
are promising but we really don't have
the theory to analyze how they perform
and we don't have the quantum computer
yet to test them and the point of this
talk I'd like to tell you is that so v7
let me program me belongs to these two
less categories so we can have full Nova
speed ups and I hope I can convince you
that it is a promising eristic to run on
a quantum computer as well once we have
one okay so what what is some definite
programming it's
oops wait wait there's a problem the
question being appear oh there's a
second oh my computer it's there's a
volleyball beach here I'm sorry you have
to restart my powerpoints
yeah I should sorry I should be using
like Microsoft products not Apple that's
the problem but let's see yeah all right
so now seven different program is a
class of convex optimization problem and
this is very simple basically just want
to optimize a linear function with some
linear constraints over the set of
positive semi-definite matrices so we so
the objective function is maximum of
trade CX since us a square matrix X is
another square matrix which is the
variable we optimize over and they'll
have a bunch of linear constraints we
have M linear constraints and they are
all of the form trace a JX is more than
V J where AJ are the matrices and BJ are
real numbers and the phd constraints X
bigger than 0 just says that's X is a
mission and all the eigen values of X
they are bigger or equal to 0 so what
are the parameters the inputs they are n
by n a sparse matrices C 1 a 1 up to am
each one is n by n I there we assume
that they're all a sparse then each row
we have at most s nonzero elements and
we have a bunch of real numbers we want
to be m and the output we want to just
find X which no optimizes this linear
function so there is a special case
where all the images they are diagonal
this is linear programming both as to
piece 73 programming and lp's they are
very useful there are many applications
like income natural optimization
operation research and so on I don't
have actually to tell you that they're
very useful because right we use them
all all the time writing in our fields
and what one simple reasons just because
the fundamental object that we work with
all the time these matrices right there
they have a central role writing in SD
piece it looks like non-normalized NC
matrices and also they're why they are
so useful well because we actually have
a pretty good classical algorithms for
STPs
so the most used one is interior point
methods there are many different
interior point
algorithms but so the best the best
rigorous runtime is of this order like m
square and s roughly and it gives like
log 1 over Delta
the error there's also another class of
problems which is less using practices
but it's also interesting to be very
relevant for this talk it's called
multiplicative weight methods and it has
a bear dependence in terms of M yeah in
terms of M and other parameters there's
also some we'll get to that later
there's the width and the size of the
solutions which are relevant but has a
work scale in terms of the error okay
but we'll get more to this and in the
question we're not we want to address
this whether there are quantum speedups
for SCPs and lp's i think that's a
natural question but the people didn't
explore it so far and this is what we
want to do so before telling you the
results let me just define a few other
concepts about SD peas one is okay what
I present to you is called sometimes a
primal problem right this is just wanna
maximize Tracy X over a bunch of
constraints and constraints of the form
trace hjx more than vga and next being
positive semi-definite but there is also
a dual problem Abdul SDP and it has the
following form we just want to minimize
the inner product of B with Y right so
just sum over I bi Y I and then we have
just 1 we have one positive
semi-definite constraint as well but now
it's of the form of some of J YJ AJ
bigger equal to 2 see the matrix C and
now we require that the vector Y Y is
the vector now is an M dimensional
vector component wise all the components
are bigger or equal to 0 ok so that's
that's a different STP right and and the
point is that under mild conditions not
always but pretty much like almost
always and we assume that the SDP is the
way that we work with they have this
prophesy the solution of the primal is
equal to the optimal value of the prime
is equal to the optional value of the
dual so you can choose which one you
want to solve the one is which is more
convenient to you and we are going to
explore that so let's to parameters that
I have to introduce before going to the
results yes this movie passive weight
methods does and as our algorithm we
will do it also depends on two other
parameters apart from the Espace C and
the size of the matrices and the number
of constraints these are like you can
call the problems related to the size of
the solutions the optional solutions so
suppose we have a optimal primal so
you can pick any one you want if there
is more than one the our parameter is
just an upper bound on the trace of the
optimal solution of the primal problem
okay so I this okay this matrix is
positive semi-definite so this trace is
the same as the one arm so if it tells
us how big the one of the officer
solution is like the shut-in one or the
dual we'll do the same thing but now it
is a vector there are some solutions so
we care about the one arm off of this
vector okay and a small apartment just
tell us how big it is all right so
before getting to the results let's do
some limitation of on what we could what
we should be able to achieve so first if
you just want to write down the
solutions the optimal solution of the
primal problem is an N by n positive
semi definite matrix so this requires
roughly n square parameters right so
that's if you want to write down the
solution you need at least at for the
primal you need at least M or the M time
but suppose you want to do something
legs we just want to compute the optimal
value we don't care about writing down
the option solutions then we still have
some lower bounds so there is a easy
reduction to search problem Island I'm
not going to give the details well let
me just mention the results to compare
with the performance of the algorithm
later so there is a classical lower
bound of order n plus M okay and all the
other parameters they are the small R
and big R and this part CS and the arrow
Delta they are constants then if you
need time n plus M classically and
qantas unit time square root of n plus
square root of M we don't know if that's
optimal there is also a posted this
afternoon by a toad on a Gillian
debris and the wolf and and they improve
his results so they can get sharper
results like of all the N times M when M
is roughly equals to M but with
everything concept but not days more our
parameter okay and that's and they'll be
relevant but I encourage you to see
their poster later on so what are the
results we get so so the first results
is that there is a quantum algorithm for
solving SC peas and the runtime is
square root in n the size of the
matrices is keratin M the number of
constraints squared is positive and some
polynomial in in some log n m and it is
are kept ORS more arms in the error and
I'll tell you what we have some bounds
on this polynomial it's pretty bad buy
or get to this so
so what is they put again is an N by n s
pass matrices see a 1 to M and the real
numbers we assumed is normalization
that's the the operator norm of AI NCS
is more than one if you don't it's fine
but then we just have to you know there
will be extra term in the complexity
related to the size of the norms and
what is the outputs okay so because we
have some linear complex in nm we should
not be able to write down the option
solution right so we have to be happy of
doing something less than that and what
we require from the algorithm is that
apart from estimating the optimal value
we are just able to sample from a
probability distribution or this should
be one norm probability solution equals
to Y divided by the one norm of Y right
such as normalized sorry this is a type
in the value of the one or not or and
quantum samples from a quantum state
which is just the normalized of the
solution and the value of the trees okay
so and of course we want to estimate the
well the optimal value up to some
additive error Delta so the output form
if you remember the h HL quantum
operational in equations has a similar
flavor right we output the solutions at
quantum states here we output the
solution either as a probability
solution or there's a density matrix
depending on if you want to solve the
prime or other do a problem okay so
that's the dais was okay but now how we
access the matrix right see in a 1 to am
weary as with assume that we do we have
the the number setting in chrome Plex we
just have Oracle which outputs any
chosen nonzero entry of these matrices
at unit cost so you just have for
insists j KL z je labels the choice of
the matrix Kayla was the role of the
particular matrix L labels the L nonzero
element and then we just put the value
of this elf nonzero element of the K
flow of the Jeff matrix in in the fourth
register okay so that's just a standard
thing okay so there is some some people
about this - first it if right we has an
unconditioned condition of quadratic
speed-up in terms of either N or M not
both for the same time that we don't
know well cuz I show you this classical
lower bound of n plus M and it is not so
far away from optimal in the quantum
case right with everything else
we need at least time square root of n
plus square root of M so that's there is
some room for improvement but not so
much
there's someone also really bad parks
the dependence on the other parameters
there aerbook at the moment okay so they
like the product of is small R with V R
to the power of 32 and air whatever L to
the power of 18 so not very practical so
but hopefully we have time to to fix
this on should we have a quantum
computer so but yeah so I think that
there's a link they just improve your
analogies should be able to improve
these a lot but also if you really want
to get this to some very small values we
might have so we have to some new ideas
so that's a good open problem in a you
know a bad things out that is close to
optimal right so in general we won't
have superpolynomial speed ups here okay
so the best thing we can expect in
general in the worst case are our
polynomial speed ups of the form that we
have here okay that's what we thought
just just a special case we're going to
get that more later if the SDP has the
profits that all the coefficients are
bigger than one they BJ coefficients
then this depends on the size of the
dual solution drops out so we don't have
it anymore
okay so that's the storm servation
alright so now a second result so
suppose we cannot have a larger speed
ups in general but can we have some
innovating in some instances so can we
have when can we have larger speed ups
and we have a result on that so we also
have a quantum algorithm for solving
SDPs
and it runs in time see chips we get to
that what is the crucial number then
square root m in the in terms of the
number of constraints we don't improve
it so much but now there is only one
logarithm dependence on n and that's the
big portion thing so what is this T
gives this roughly is just the time we
need on a quantum computer to prepare
some family of quantum states which
we'll call deep states in there of this
form they're just exponential of linear
combination of the input matrices of the
problem right so a I and C there if the
input matrix of the problem this new I
coefficients they are just some real
numbers that we have to vary over them
if we can prepare this kind of give
States efficiently for any choice of new
ice coefficients which are not so big
they are like smaller than order log n
poly one over Delta
then you know then that's the let's
delete the order of the of the
performance of the algorithm so what
this means is that we can just now use
quantum get simply for example could use
quantum Metro please as a receipt here
right so maybe usually it's very hard to
to analyze how how quickly a system
thermalize we are in interesting unison
how like we can think of this linear
combination of the input matches as a
quantum Hamiltonian and we understand
how quickly you can prepare that give
States that's a hard problem but maybe
if you have a quantum computer can just
try and and see if we have a good job
and if you're lucky in the families h is
quick what i mean quick is just like
polynomial in the number of qubits here
which is now poly log in n because n is
the dimension of the matrix then we can
have the largest pinups and i I think
that's nice but this gives an
application of quantum Gibbs sampling
outside just simulating thermal
properties of physical systems so we
know classically give sampling is a very
useful algorithm to this gives I guess
one example in the quantum case as well
all right so now we have a he says well
we can have this large speed up so we
can prove we have these large speed ups
but it is a I feel a bit contrived but I
think you interesting let me tell you
how it is and is when we have these
matrices as like quantum data so the
result is that we also have a quantum
algorithm for SC peas there runs in
times square root of M but now Polly log
N and direct and other parameters then
we have a new problem which is the rank
of the matrices if the matrix if the
data is given quantum form so what is
that we assumed there is an Oracle that
given I outputs not an entry of I
anymore but outputs the eigenvalues of
AI and output also the eigen vectors s
quantum states just prepare these
quantum states and we assume rank is
just a maximal rank of all the matrices
so this works well when the matrices are
low rank such that we can just write
down all the eigen states as quantum
states and all the eigen values ok and
the idea is very simple one get to that
but it's just because of these two
assumptions low rank and quantum data
you can show that on a quantum computer
we can just easily prepare that give
states that we need we can just do they
give simply efficiently and that's
that's how it works so in times poly log
N and reign
of them matrices of course the
limitation is not clear how relevant
disease and also is likely how we should
compare this with classroom efforts
right but I think it's it shows that you
know we might we might have bigger speed
ups some cases so now what I want to do
is to give you a idea of how to get this
out with you know I won't start with a
special case of SCP which is well
understood array and and probably most
many of you know how to do it which is
to compute the maximum eigen value of a
matrix of a sparse matrix so computing
the maximum eigen value of a sparse
matrix C is a semi definite problem is
just this one extremely simple right we
just maximize Tracy X such that the
trace of x equals one is the basic
matrix right so and X is bigger or equal
to zero so this gives the maximum value
these are well sorry problem right so
okay many times we say the minimum I get
head is the same we just do four minus C
and one way to do that right a heuristic
way of course that's a hard problem in
general right it's just like you and me
hearts but we can still try to do it
sometimes and one interesting way of
doing that is using quantum annealing
and we just cool down the Hamiltonian
right we just cool down - see try to do
whatever on States and it's easy
calculation if you can prepare the give
States it's the bitter a see for some
inverse temperature for the log n over
Delta then we can compute the maximum
eigen value error that okay so if we can
cut down to sufficient low temperatures
we can solve this problem of course not
always we can but now let me just tell
you how these square roots are appearing
in the in the complex in the worst case
they already appear here and this was
analyzed I think first by Poulin version
and there are many other paper since I
giving different alternatives or just
improving parameters so the result is
that you can actually prepare these Gib
states for s Part C in time roughly this
all children means that there's some
hidden poly log sectors when x roughly
is Part C times square root n on a
quantum computer so my evil you could do
that sometimes s times n right but one
computer have this square root spindle
and the idea is pretty standard actually
just use phase summation amplitude
amplification so let's say I be the
eigenstates of C and ya
the eigenvalues they were II could do
you prepare the Maxima entangled states
you can write the max when tango sit in
any base you want you right in the eigen
state basis so is this some of our I
psyops I I I'm not putting
normalizations here then you do pay the
summation and just learn you know they
just write down the value of the energy
associated to the eigenstates you just
do the operation with like you have an
extra concealer if they are silly 0 you
just put this bottom weight in front if
it's 1 you put the other thing to be a
normalized state and what you can show
is that if you just pull select on the
on Cilla cubed be 0 you get a
purification of the Gib state which is
what you want but of course the
probabilities more you can the
probabilities if you do the math you
just be of order 1 over m can be bigger
sometimes but like the worst case would
be of order 1 over n now what you can do
is just use up its amplitude
amplification to boost to measuring to
getting the purification with a very
good probability but it needs a number
of interaction which is like roughly
right square root 1 or a probability so
a square root n so that's the idea and
to get this worst-case performance
basically what we like to do is
something very similar to that but for
general esta peas right and and then and
then what is not clear is how how can
solve general esta means basically just
preparing quantum Gibb States and this
is what I want explain how to do and
lucky this in okay this was done first
impacts classically there is a algorithm
by Aurora and cable which is if you read
it is really there is like some cotton
give States there and therefore that's
there was our motivation for okay leads
so the quantum algorithm is based on on
a classical algorithm for STP is due to
our RN k
from 2007 it's based on these mutant
kratsov weight methods I want to review
their methods but just before for now
we're going to assume that be eyes are
all bigger than the one in the general
case there is a reduction which just
reduce any case so this case but there
is like this extra blocking complex of
order poly are but we are not going to
consider that and because we have these
up around so we can without loss of
generality just assume that the first
matrix is identity and the Bab one
associated with teachers are right this
just gives the constraint that trace X
is more than R which by the finish is
true by definition of our
all right so let me tell you they are
our rhythm but in they are way from
there is a subroutine that octillery
algorithm which is called the Oracle and
it is a very simple linear programming
with just two constraints let me tell
you what it is this just Oracle of a
density matrix Rho just search for a
vector Y which satisfies two constraints
one y should belong to a sets the Omega
sort the Alpha which is the set of all
vectors for which all elements are
bigger than zero and the inner product
of B Y is smaller than alpha where alpha
is a parameter that I'm going to show
you how to choose later and it is
another constraint which if you if you
notice is just the positive
semi-definite constraint of the dual
problem is somewhere with a a j YJ minus
is big or equal to zero here we're just
taking the trace of that with row this
should be bigger than zero so it's kind
of we are relaxing the pse constraints
that we have on the dual program just to
some limit so some linear constraint now
this all we have is a LP with free
constraints action right right so let's
let's think about how to solve this
Oracle later but what is their algorithm
so that you start from some daisy matrix
which is the max in the mix one Row one
then we have some arrow parameter
epsilon which depends on on the accuracy
Delta in this our parameter and we
integrate three times and C is roughly R
square Ln n over del T Square and what
is this integration well first you just
run Oracle on the matrix Rho T and we
get this vector white C then you
construct some matrix which depends on
YT and on the input matrices M G then
you complete the give set of this matrix
which is Rho T plus 1 right that's just
the give set associated to this well to
the sum of the previous and my points
and you integrate that like a lot very
few many times and in the end you output
some Y which is the average of the Y T
plus some correction just to make things
work and this would be a good solution
so what they show is that this y bar the
inner product is close to the optimum in
is always is oh whoops this would be one
plus the other times alpha so alpha
imagine just a guess for the option
solution and we just very alpha by
binary search to get off the solution
and this shows again the background
be like bigger than 1 plus Delta
everything times off ok so so you're
close to you can certify they're smaller
than alpha up to some is more error
how about sides I have there
okay so maybe let me yeah ok I don't
know how I should get to the quantum
algorithm bulimics though we have to do
a classical before so so why this works
so first it's easy to see why this y bar
has a small objective value right so by
definition right all elements are bigger
than than 0 so that that's good of the
inner part is also more than alpha so if
you just do the map of the inner product
of Y bar with B you you have this more
correction which gives Delta x alpha and
then all the other terms here all the
white C times B by definition a small in
alpha so you get the object value is not
to be that's good but what we really
care about why the the harder fee is
whether the positive semi-definite
constraints is satisfied so much check
that Y bar is feasible and from the
Oracle we know that the the expectation
value of this matrix sum of a JY j th a
minus c on roads is bigger than 0 but
what we need is that this matrix is
positive semi-definite so we want to
boost from being north of the trace on
some matrix being bigger than 0 so all
to the trace on all matrix being bigger
than 0 and this is what this major
smooth passing weight method does for us
there are many instance of its we are
interested in a matrix version of it
here so we are given what it says we
give an N by n matrices M of T and some
error and then you can bounce so here we
just take the average of the expectation
value of Rothesay with empty and it is
always smaller than some small term 1
plus epsilon times the time the minimum
eigen value of this of the average of
the matrices
up to some additive correction which
when T is bigger goes to 0 so this says
that if you want to specify that the sum
of the mix or the average of the
matrices is positive semi-definite you
can do that just by computing the
expectation value on this matrix rotc
right when y is roxy is just the gift
states of the sum of of the matrices so
this is exactly what we need there is
interpretation in terms of two player
zero-sum game that I won't get into that
but you see the flavor right why this
works we from the Oracle we know that
this expectation value Mirage is bigger
than zero but because of this mmw method
this implies that actually the whole
matrix is positive semi-definite which
is what we want okay so I run out of
time let me just roughly sketch what we
change in this hour okay or rhythm to
get the quantum version so implements we
make it quantum as follows so first
first to implement Oracle while we have
to implement this Oracle ok think by we
do it by Gibbs same thing as well so we
show that we can also map this linear
program to a Gibbs sampling problem and
then we do that to produce this vector
white C and we apply amplitude
amplification solve this in time roughly
the main complex of the away from and I
show you why this is the complex at this
step there is also not a step this empty
they are not really there are some of
sparse matrices but there are many of
them so the overall wouldn't be dead
sparse and of course to implement get
simply officially we need a sparse
matrix so it just specifies we just like
do some run on simply and we get some
over or like some bar M T matrix which
is associated to the original empty
matrix just by you know instead of
having a white C vector here with just
sample from a distribution given by the
normalized white C and then K so there
is to close the matrices so that's fine
and we do give simply again for the road
C we prepare this as a quantum states
but nowadays pacified version and this
has time this is s square times square
root of n so why we get this complex let
me just explain a little bit more so
what we can show and I won't be able to
tell you but that's there is always a
feasible white see this fall's from
James principle of max entropy basically
of the form some normalization n times
the probability bution QT which is of
the Gibbs form and we know what what is
the gift of what is the Hamiltonian of
the gift States is just super efficient
slung the and move that we have to vary
over there are real coefficients that we
don't know what they are we just good
for search them but times the
constraints of the LP right one
constrains this trace a I wrote C and
another constraints that B is right so
so we can just we already have to do is
prepare give states of this form but ok
so we can do give same
in amplitude amplification here that's
fine but to do that we need the Oracle
to the entries of H right and if you see
the interest of age they depend on on a
quantum state watch see that we also
have to prepare so here what we have to
do to simulate Oracle to the entries of
H we have to prepare the states ROTC and
measure them with the observos AI
depending on the intra double wanna
estimates so what is the time for that
well to prepare each ROTC right this is
just like normal Gibbs sampling this
takes time is roughly s squared square
root of n but simple cutesy we write too
simple to achieve doing a pizza
complication Gibson this requires
roughly square root M Oracle calls to
the Oracle 4-h so each which each codes
the arc of H takes times roughly s
square square root of n so we get a
total complex so that's very roughly how
how it appears I have to maybe I will
not tell you about that let me just do
conclusion open problem so I show you
that quantum computers provide speed up
from st piece but i but there are many
things that has to be proved okay so one
right that we we can we prove the
parameters like this small big R small R
and Delta there they're really bad
performance at the moment right I think
there is a lot of room for improvement
but it would be just to see what the
limits are also can we find the awesome
of our in terms of n MN s it's kind of
close right the lower and upper bound
but there are gaps so be nice to close
these gaps second can we find some
relevant settings where there are super
polynomial speed ups there will be very
interesting maybe we might have to wait
and see we have a quantum computer but
maybe not maybe we can understand this
better also very issue seeing a feature
of the algorithm is that we only use a
quantum computer to prepare deep states
okay so and then you can think we and
gives it a temperature is not so small
it's like it's small but it's not like
it's your temperature so maybe there is
some inherent robustness to air of the
algorithm that we could explore and I
don't know that's the interesting
question and related to deaths if you
can improve the parameters and if there
is a robust as to error right because
the quantum computer is only used for
Gibbs sampling is there potentially a
nice application for a small size phone
compete
could we could we actually run this if
you have some more size quanta computer
with no error correction that's also
question that I would like to explore
more so that's it thank you so we have
plenty of time for questions
well yeah Murphy actually
their simple reason you choose a
specification of the of the matrix to be
lock of order Lock em and if you change
the scaling affect our scaling of big
our can repeat the question so that this
Login what I mean like it wasn't this
like a lot Horsham yes is there simple
reason you choose us to specify to lock
I mean log M is what we have to specify
to for the two matrix to be close to
each other and it's also good for us
because this log n factor is we don't
care about it because it's much smaller
than their right then they scored in
fact that we have anyway so that's why I
was happy with it but actually you need
at least this log M if you'll not do
this log and then you specify this
pacify too much and they are not close
anymore but it's what game is also
wouldn't not first right because it's
it's very small
well my question is about your last
comment and your conclusion so can you
think of like application of SDP where
it's obvious that the this the way the
output is given by just sampling yeah
where it can be useful or just like some
some classical problem where that would
be enough yeah i i'm not sure but i mean
you you love you because you always
learn the the optimum value at least
right so you but i don't know actually
have a question which may be an answer
to that
yeah so i was thinking about cases when
you have a you want to have a high
dimensional SGP yeah where the entries
are succinctly described so one example
of this is the dps hierarchy for
searching for over over separable states
have you thought about how that fits
into these parameters yeah right so the
problem is you actually have mentioned
that but because the very bad depends on
only small R and big are usually for
applications we are not getting speed
ups so that's a yeah let's draw back so
we have we should be we have to improve
on that before we can set up line two
yeah I saw like they suggest efficient
in getting improvement I also have a
related question so hopefully sighs we
have to specify all these entries and
and and how hard is this to actually oh
this will disinfect the running time you
mean you mean if you have an arrow in
the entries of the input matrices how it
effects yes yeah so that's that's why I
think you ready to draw buses to error
so you care about give states at okay so
suppose you let's just normalize like
the physics where I suppose the the
Hamiltonian scales of number of
particles that's an realization then the
temperature would just be something a
constants proportion a one of error they
want so there is more but constant
temperature now imagine that you just
have no some perturbation the
Hamiltonian then the question is how
much defects the expectation value of
the give states on some rights or some
age then and sometimes can be bets but I
think
it'll be okay right so so I hear there
needs to be hopeful I think but it
remains to be seen
can you yeah
do you think that dependence on the
sparsity should be polynomial or do you
think you can get some speed up for
dense matrices so the should be
polynomial and and there is a is also
but I like wrong the Walken and and his
collaborators they also have this they
there's a simple a nice argument that
this s square is necessary like yeah so
any other questions hi so you're using
this amplitude amplification to
quadratically speed up some of the
algorithms that you're using here right
yes so in some other scenario let's say
for example measure and replace where
you have you wanna prepare grid ground
state of some prism highlighters could
you also use a medium amplification to
get quadratic speed ups there so for
ground states like for example in
measuring the plays algorithm let's say
I don't want the measuring replaces but
yeah there is also similar results to
prepare the ground state off am anybody
here with Tony and then you can do all
since car with n time I see okay it's
good it's by a few obvious all right
okay if there are no more questions
let's thank for now to again for a nice
talk
[Applause]